hi thanks Tamara so I will start with
the introductions first of all thank you
everybody from ply data Global to
joining us today you've probably heard
of polers by now right this is
definitely not the first polers talk um
this conference or many Pi conferences
in recent
months so the point of this talk is not
meant to be just another introduction to
poers right the me the point of this
talk is to introduce our Endeavor so
Funk time is one of the first python
data science libraries built almost
entirely in
polers and we're going to show how we
rewrote one of the most widely
downloaded time series libraries TS
fresh with over
180,000 downloads in a month into polers
and
rust and we hope that this talk would
match to you so what match it to you
because
hopefully we can demonstrate that polers
is in fact production ready that by
grating your existing pandas and numpy
codebase into p and rust is a very
reasonable Endeavor if we can do it I'm
sure so can you and of course the result
of that is faster run times moving away
from
pandas into a rust based polish runtime
fewer clock Cycles right polers are some
really smart optimizations under the
hood and lastly lower memory usage in
particular from polar's really smart uh
smart use of the arrow colmer
format so just a quick run through our
agenda the first part of this talk would
just give an introduction to what is PS
fresh like what does it actually do and
what it does is something called time
feature extraction we're going to
explain why this Panda numpy based
Library TS fresh was so popular and
explain what were some of his
limitations that led us to rewrite it in
in fun
time and after that I'll pass over the
Flor and Matthew he will describe give
code examples and tips and tricks on how
to apply it to your own to your own code
base if you do do decide to migration in
this
style okay so I will give a brief
introduction to time series and what is
time series feature extraction
um so first what is a Time series so
it's a series of data point indexed in a
time order so as an example you have uh
on the right hand side the stock price
you can also have sales data or any kind
of data that is uh time related or time
indexed um so once you have those data
you can of course extract features so
the process of extracting features is
basically take those row data and uh
extract character ities properties and
attributes on them so as you can see the
stock price you trans you can transform
in Array of data and you can extract
meaningful features so here you have an
example with simple features such as the
mean max number of pics and so on so it
could be a scalar value but also a list
of values um yeah okay so in this talk
we are going to um to use the panel data
long format um so basically it's when
you have multiple time series stack on
top of each others and um this panel
data format is extremely nice because
you can have all your time series and
all the values um just uh in one long uh
format and usually the first column
represent the ID the second the time and
the third the upsert values so in thisa
in this example you have um Commodities
price so the ID will be the commodity in
question then the time will be uh the
price at this specific date and then to
observe values uh the the price in this
case um so some other examples to use
this um panel data format could be sell
AC cross product in a retail store uh so
basically your product will be the
the the ID of your uh panel data and
then you have the time and then let's
say the quantity that you uh you selling
or um the P the um quantity in dollars
that you are selling this specific day
or month then you can have also the turn
rate across uh customer segments so the
ID will be the customer segments and
observe value will be the turn rate uh
at a specific uh interval of time and
finally it could be sensor data across
machines in a factory so then the ID
will be the machine um so the ID of the
machine and then the uh observed value
could be the temperature the pressure uh
measured in a regular interval of
time so um now that we have uh
introduced the subject of Time series
and feature extraction and which data
format we are using I can talk a little
bit more about TS fresh so it's a
extremely famous uh library to do
feature extraction uh because it
contains more than 100 time series
feature extraction methods so it's quite
quite large uh it's very easy to use so
you can uh basically in a single line
extract um many many features with pre
specified um
parameters um so it's it's nice because
out of the box you can directly calc
calculate some some features and also
it's flexible because you can provide a
list of uh dictionary that will be the
parameters that you you use for the
calculation of of your
features um so you have many use cases
uh the first one could be classification
so let's say you have un label uh time
series you have multiple unlabeled time
series some labeled Time series and you
want to label the unlabeled uh one so
what you will usually do I mean what you
can do is that you calculate uh features
uh on all of them and then you uh can
associate an unlabeled one with a
labeled one sharing similar uh
characteristics then you have also a
regression task so um if you want to
predict future um let's say price uh of
a stock what you can do is is include
features from many different other
series that could impact uh the price um
of a stock let's say um so this is a
different another use case and finally
an anomaly detection so if your sensor
um so if You observe some um strain
values with feature extraction you can
easily remove those values uh for a
given
criteria so why from time re wrote this
fresh in polars uh so it's a good
question and to uh answer this question
I will first introduce Funtime and then
uh introduce polar as well so Funtime is
a machine learning library for time
series prediction uh so it it allows you
to uh perform Global forecasting on
panel data format so basically you can
uh use multiple time series to predict
the uh future values of one uh one of
them then you have also preprocessing
tasks so you can do for example first
different uh different differences if
you want to make your uh time series
stationary or you can use box CX to have
a look like data that look like the
normal distribution then you can also
perform cross validation with fun time
uh so you can take your training um
training sets and split in different
folds uh so it will uh improve the
performance of your uh model and finally
you can do time series feature
extraction for both expression and polar
expression and polar series
uh so this this talk is mainly about
this time series feature uh
extraction so for polars um so Chris
mentioned it but probably you know
already but it's a quer on G written in
Rust with a data frame API so under the
hood it uses a row as the memory model
so it's this um columnar memory format
which allow you to perform a very
efficient operation um then it's
multi-threaded so it will use the the
threat of your um of your uh CPU on your
machine so uh it it will allow you to
perform operation very fast especially
um in specific context um also you have
to optimize lazy queries um so instead
of um executing directly your operation
what you can do is that uh you specify
your operation in a lazy mode and then
you uh execute them only uh once you
have have defined all of them and it it
helps the somehow the compiler can do a
further optimization in such a case and
finally it handles data set larger than
memory so now I will um hand it to creas
and is going to explain you why what was
the motivation uh to include this into
Fun
Time right so tsfresh is an incredible
library right super convenient in just
one on line code you can generate many
many different features for your time
series but it's starting to show his age
so it's was first released almost six
years ago and in particular it's
starting to have limitations both in
terms of performance when you want to
scale to not just one time series but
many but can compute like hundreds of
Time series for n number uh n number of
Time series so the panel data format on
top of that it also has what might be an
outdated API design so no type hints a
few non-explicit keyword arguments and
we found that polers with its fantastic
use of multi threading with its
fantastic use of efficient me memory you
know data structs and particular a list
type was able to address many of these
limitations and as we continue doing
this rewrite many more interesting tips
and tricks that we learned and that's
why for the rest of the talk mattio
provide code examples for how you would
use this in fun time and also how you
might apply some of our learnings to
your own codebase
migration okay thank you Chris um so now
I will give you I will show show you uh
quick code example um so let's say you
have a data frame in a a panel format
and um you want to calculate some
features so what you will do uh is that
for each of the time series you want to
calculate features so what you will do
is that you will perform a group by
operation so in this case um for the for
the the specific ID so the First Column
and then you will aggregate so the so
this section um as you can see we
calculate polar features so very simple
one so Max mean and mean and this is uh
what is coming out of the box with
polars but what you can do is with fun
time um just with a small uh differences
you will use this register expression
name space uh so in this case called t
yes and then you can calculate a bit
more complex features that has been
developed uh within fun time so you can
see the code uh doesn't become too uh
too complex and it's extremely easy to
use and stay consistent with the polars
API okay so um now that I show this uh
quick code example I will explain a
little bit The Benchmark with did so we
wanted to compare TS fresh leveraging
pandas and um versus Funtime l aing um
polars so the first one that we we did
is that we wanted really to compare the
performance um of a single feature
without any context so what we did is
that we um we took the M4 data set with
9 million rows and we're comparing
calculating a single filter on a single
Vector um containing N9 minion rows and
um and comparing the speed up so as you
can see in this table uh ranked of
course by speed up uh it's it's faster
our implementation is is faster what I
would like to mention uh is that for the
10 last features we are actually slower
but this is something that we are
working on so I want it to be
transparent for this um so okay this is
The Benchmark for the uh features on
themselves so now we did also another
Benchmark so we took the S&P 500 with
120k rows and we were calculating the
features in a group by context so we
were calculating the features for each
of the stock and The observed value that
we we had so it was the price in this in
this case and as you can see uh using
the the power um so the multi threaded
power of Pol we're uh we managed to have
a insane insane speed up and in this
case um all the features were actually
faster Okay so okay so now uh I would
like to talk a little bit about the the
learning that
we um the things we learned all together
so with this community of contributors
and we made the top seven of them uh
about polars and Funtime so the first
one is that polar is a very expressive
language um so the method that you will
use uh St exp explicitly what it does
and it makes quite easy to underst
understand a code just by uh aun
function just by reading the code
immediately so you have this r e
function for example so it's uh it
calculates the length of runs of
identical uh
values and we use it in a feature um
that calculates the length of the
longest consecutive subsequence in X
that is bigger than the mean of X so
it's longest strike above mean so you
can see on the left hand side uh is the
fun time implementation and on the right
hand side is the T TS flesh one and and
um you can see that this R methods is
exactly the equivalent of this get
length sequence where and um I think you
can immediately see that uh the when you
read this code it's a bit easier to
understand for you so it's quite an
expressive language in this regard then
the second learning that we we have is
that Polar Polar name space are awesome
and clean um so as I showed in the code
example you just need to add this this
little ts. the name of the feature and
to do so you can uh basically use what
what is made available um by Pol so use
this decorator to register your
expression name space so in this case I
register the TS um expression name space
then you define your class uh you have a
Constructor with only one attribute
which is the expression and then you can
Define all the uh features and this is
how we created this uh
all this set of features for Polar
expression then the third learning is
that the common sub expression uh
elimination is a very powerful features
of
Po so if you don't know what it is it's
basically a compiler optimization that
is searching for instances of identical
Expressions so let's say you have a huge
uh data frame you want to calculate many
features on on it and you know that you
will do a lot of repeated computation so
for example you in many different
features you will calculate the mix the
mean the absolute value and so on if you
are in the case of a lazy um lazy query
um polars will basically calculate it
once and then reuse it multiple times so
this is what you can see in this example
so you define your uh polar lazy frame
then you apply the context with column
and then by using the explain method you
can see uh the optimization that has
been made by the uh compiler
okay so the fourth learning is that rust
and polars is a valuable alternative for
scientific Computing to numai and numai
so this is true in specific use cases um
so for example a code that cannot be
completely vectorized um so this
function is a Benford correlation so the
Benford law states that um leading digit
is likely to be small in a real uh data
set and what what it calculates is that
it will take the distribution of the
leading digit of your time series and
then calculate the correlation with this
benord law and um to do so you you will
uh perform some string
operation so to extract the leading
digit and this this is of course a code
that cannot be completely vectorized and
uh it's extremely fast using polars as
you can uh see in The
Benchmark then also um
it's it's quite adequate to use uh polar
for manipulation on a singal vector one
of the example is index Mass quantile so
the index Mass quantile calculate the
relative index of the time series X
where q% of the mass lies left to the to
this relative index and as it will
calculate some features on this uh
single index uh single Vector sorry it
uh polar uh is quite fast for
this um then also a learning that we
something that we learned during the
development is that um T fresh is very
nice library and it's largely our work
is lar largely inspired from from it but
we um we we were thinking that uh you
can improve a lot this API and this is I
think what we did so for example for
energy ratio by chunks um so so for this
feature you will take your time series
divide it into two chunks and calculate
the energy ratio and then other energy
and then you will calculate it as a
ratio such as the sum will be equal to
one so in TSR you can see that you need
to provide an argument param which will
which which will be um a list of
dictionary and we think that this is not
the uh best way to define a feature
especially because then it return a list
of tle uh which which is
um uh um a bit weird to to handle I will
say um and what we did with fun time is
that we just provided simple arguments
uh in such a way and then we were
returning a list of list where uh every
chunk was just indexed by the list
index then also um to improve a little
bit the API for the change quantiles um
so basically the change quantiles you
will calculate the distribution of your
uh 10 series then you will uh select
only a corridor within two quantiles and
within this Corridor you will compute
the changes so XT minus XT minus
one and in in uh TS fresh case what they
were doing is that they're uh
aggregating as a string argument and
then returning a float so in this case
the mean and we think that it's um just
better to let the user do uh do this
calculation himself so if if he wants to
use the mean the median or whatever uh
you could do this and therefore we were
returning a list of list so you could
just do do list dot uh mean if you
wanted to uh calculate the mean in the
same way as TS
fres um then another very nice uh
feature of Pol is the poas plug-in
system so if you want to uh write uh
write your expression as a rust function
so you can compile this rust function
and register an expression into the
polars library um and for this you need
mainly three ingredients so rust
installed mat in buil system which is
the equivalent of set set of tools
somehow and then uh the polar plugin uh
system and for this we we have one
example uh that tein was implementing so
the Leen
complexity so the leive complexity is
Computing uh the number of different
substring that you can find in a binary
sequence reading from left to right uh
so it's uh basically it Returns the
value that a value that represent um if
the binary sequence is regular or not so
the if it's low then it's uh it's quite
regular uh and so this implementation
has been made by tein um so ISO ponm is
abstract QQQ and uh this work has been
um influenced by B so you can have a
look at the code in the repo if you're
interested to um also Implement a rust
function to make it compatible as a
polar
expression and uh the final learning is
that uh we're implementing a iterative
development approach and strategic
division of work and I think this is
what uh what made this work quite
successful because uh quite fast were so
we were eight developers at the
beginning we were uh uh we divided the
work to implement
um 10 features each and then in the
meantime we were writing unit test and
optimize the the features to have a very
good uh good quality of code and
something that uh that that will be uh
very reliable in time so we were very
underling with edge cases and optimizing
so I'm I'm quite proud that we managed
to write all those un unit tests and uh
be able to present something that is uh
uh quite reliable to the users
so then the uh final um element that I
would like to mention is why would you
use fun time for the features uh
extraction so the first argument would
be the speed because as you can see if
you have many time series on very large
data set you can really leverage the
predefined set of of features that we
have made available but also all the
capabilities from Po and I think we have
to recognize that uh this work is is
quite
amazing but uh it's on only not only the
the it's not only this argument but also
the fact that uh the API is very um
consistent and it's um extremely easy to
to use so even if you have a small data
set I think it would make sense because
uh it will uh make your code uh a bit
easier to read and also easier to debug
so there is this famous quote that I I
took on LinkedIn came for for the speed
State for the syntax and I think it
applies quite well for polars but also
for fun time as it has been developed in
the same uh Paradigm in the same uh idea
so I would like to thank all our
contributors and especially abstract QQQ
who made a lot of work to optimize all
the features and is uh very active in
this regard and the polar um
ecosystem and the next step uh uh for
the feature extraction part will be to
provide a wrapper around 100 of press
specified uh features such as the one in
TS fresh also do feature selection based
on statistical significance um so this
is what's this is something that was
also available in TS fresh and finally I
would like to mention that we are commun
Community Driven and join our Discord if
you want to ask question or um give some
uh feedback about the the the use of of
Funtime now is the time for Q&A so thank
you for listening and if you have any
question feel free to
ask so I think I see one question about
um TSR uses dask to distributed
calculations have we been able to use
poers so I think early on you saw the
benchmarks for the group by operation
and folders we managed to have 200 x
speed
UPS so this is this this hopefully
answer the question about dask right in
in TS fresh because it impl mement
features in numpy you have to use
something like dask to distribute that
code for each time series so you're
Computing 100 of features for each time
series paralyze using desk what's great
about polers is with a simple do group
bu or if you want to do rolling
features. group byor dynamic you get
that same
paralyzation but on a single instance
right with extremely fast greedy work
stealing and significantly faster sort
of scheduling of work than desk because
you're no longer sort of communicating
between different workers is all done on
a single instance uh hopefully that
answers the question
GES um for Marco's question about do we
accept Panda data frames not at the
moment so so we made the explicit
decision decision when we first created
Funk time to make it a
polar only Library as a way to enforce
that discipline as developers of this
library to make sure we use only polers
and we want to maintain this
philosophy uh moving forward unless
there's a strong argument why we would
want to accept pandas because I think
it's relatively simple for the developer
to do that themselves outside of
Funtime